[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de l'atalaye
d'interdire la statue de colbert devant
l'assemblée nationale a été vandalisée
aujourd'hui à part il est reproché au
ministre de louis xiv d'avoir été un
représentant je cite de la négrophobie
d'état il n'y a pas qu'en france que
l'on s'attaque aux statuts c'est pareil
aux états unis en grande bretagne en
italie en belgique en nouvelle-zélande
en amérique latine alors faut-il juger
les hommes du passé avec les critères
d'aujourd'hui est faut-il respecter
toutes les sensibilités de toutes les
minorités de toutes les diversités
pour en débattre nous avons invité
françoise vergès les politologues
historienne vous avez présidé le comité
national pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
vous êtes également membre du collectif
des colonisés lézard votre dernier livre
s'intitule d'ailleurs un féminisme des
colonials il est paru à la fabrique
l'année dernière est ce que vous pensez
françoise vergès qu'il faut déboulonner
certaines statues oui tout à fait et
rend fous rires je vous rappeler que ce
sont des statuts d'esclavagistes de de
colonisateurs de personnes qui ont conçu
et élaboré conceptualiser appliquer des
politiques raciales et politiques
racistes des massa qui ont opéré des
massacres c'est à dire c'est absolument
un pas du tout les personnes qui
devraient être parmi les héros de la
nation
dimitri casali vous avez été professeur
d'histoire géographie en banlieue en
zone d'éducation prioritaire vous avez
publié une quarantaine de livres sur la
transmission de l'histoire un certain
s'adressant aux enfants d'autres aux
adultes ou sur napoléon si vous avez
beaucoup écrit sur napoléon le dernier
votre dernier livre paru l'année
dernière concernent le sujet qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui puisqu'il s'intitule
le grand procès de l'histoire de france
il est paru chez robert laffont
pourvu aucune statue ne doit être
déboulonner c'est un problème très très
très important déboulonner les statues
aujourd'hui c'est ouvrir la boîte de
pandore du révisionnisme historique
tout simplement parce que c'est une
fuite en avant si on commence à
déboulonner les personnages aux bientôt
en noir pratiquement 80% des personnages
de l'histoire de l'humanité vont devoir
être
déboulonné parce que l'histoire bien sûr
on ne peuvent juger l'histoire en
général
l'histoire là ce que l'on fait c'est il
faut toujours replacer dans le contexte
de l'époque
1 les événements elle et les épisodes et
les personnages dont on parle est
effectivement en 785 le contact
historique et est tout autre puisque la
terre entière pratique l esclavage en
585 c'est la date de promulgation de du
code noir on reviendra au cas de colbert
mais d'abord et est ce que refusait de
célébrer ça n'est pas censuré quand on
retire louis ferdinand céline grand
écrivain est ce que nul ne conteste on
quand on le retire de la liste des
célébrations nationales 2011
on refuse de le célébrer on ne le sent
sur pas est ce que est ce que c'est une
censure que de dire cet homme ou cette
femme si elle arrivera sûrement aux
femmes un jour ou l'autre ne mérite pas
d'être célébrée par une statue mais
parce que je les statuts d'abord ce
n'est pas l'histoire elle ne raconte pas
l'histoire des statuts ce sont des choix
politiques à un moment donné opérée par
l'état ou par une ville où par exemple
gagné nice et la ligue coloniale
maritime qui veut que kelly une statue
et ce sont donc des choix à un moment
donné qui sont faits pour mettre en
avant une certaine histoire c'est pas du
tout l'histoire l'histoire elle se
trouve dans les livres d'histoire elle
n'est pas dans le bain personne mais moi
j'ai grandi à l'île de la réunion je
suis passé devant la statue de la
bourdonnais gouverneur colonial
esclavagiste
ça ne va pas raconter l'histoire de
l'esclavagé n'est jamais jamais
l'histoire d' esclavage il a appris chez
moi parce qu'à l'école on n'en n'est pas
je n'ai pas je veux dire ce sont des
choix donc on peu ces choix peuvent
changer l'histoire quand même change la
manière dont on voit l'espace on parle
de on sait bien qu'à paris sur les 750
statuer à peine trente 30 statut de
femme par exemple donc deux stations il
n'y a pas d'égalité jeudi à ses statuts
c'est quand même un monde très masculin
et énormément de militaires
énormément de guerriers énormément donc
de personnes qui ont construit l'état à
travers l'alarmé on pourrait quand même
se poser des questions je ne vois pas ce
que gaga ni apporte la statue de gagner
ni à porte à la connaissance de
l'histoire
la statue de bugeaud la statue de de
lyautey je ne vois pas ce qu'ils
apprennent je vois pas ce que ce qu'on
apprendrait en passant devant la devant
la statue du hockey gallini je n'y crois
pas une seconde
l'histoire elle s'apprend à l'école dans
les médias dans les discussions dans les
débats et de toute façon quand on entend
dire qu'elle ne se révise pas elle se
révise constamment on ouvre de nouvelles
archives
on commence à voir d'une manière
différente sinon il n'y aura pas eu
d'histoire des familles n'auraient pas
eu d'histoire des ouvriers il y aurait
pas d histoire des colonies zine
l'histoire des esclaves serait resté le
même le même réussi depuis la et puis le
jeu c'est pas moi depuis le 11e siècle
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et il y aura
certainement des révisions de l'histoire
de l'exclavage y aura certainement des
nouvelles approches et de l'histoire de
la colonisation
il y en a chaque année il va en avoir
encore cette année l'année prochaine
donc les choses mais ça c'est l'histoire
mais la mémoire pour nous mais dans les
rues sont les squares on pourrait quand
même c'est une question citoyenne dont
on pourrait discuter
elle n'est pas de l'ordre dé du pouvoir
politique ni des historiens on doit
choisir
on doit pouvoir choisir qui nous voulons
célébrer et effectivement et de dire que
certaines de ces statues sont des
insultes
c'est quand même de nous dire que votre
histoire ne compte pas elle n'a pas
d'importance
elle a absolument pas l'importance
dimitri casali et question subsidiaire
quand les les rues sont déboulonner les
statues de staline ou de lénine
à la fin du communisme ça n'était pas
une manière de censurer le passé ça
n'était pas de dire on oublie ce qui
s'est passé c'était dire tout simplement
on ne le célèbrera plus mais je vous
écoute votre réponse bien entendu pour
moi là l'histoire rassemble et l'ami la
mémoire divise donc il faut faire très
attention avec ce jeu nous sommes
vraiment en train d'ouvrir la boîte à
pandore du révisionniste parce que
effectivement il n'y a pas assez de
statut de femme je vous la corde par
exemple une personne a comme joséphine
baker n'est pas assez représentée en
france 1 puisqu'elle a eu un rôle
historique absolument considérable à
elle était agent secret et elle a donné
des renseignements très précieux pendant
l'occupation pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et c'est vrai qu'il y a peu de
statut de joséphine baker passe
joséphine baker qui est devenue la
première star internationale au monde
grâce à la france je le rappelle c'est
elle qui a écrit c'est la france qui m'a
fait je lui dois ma vie donc là il faut
faire très attention parce que nous
sommes en train de plaquer des
représentations mentales américaine nous
assistons à une américanisation de la
pensée sur l'histoire de france qui n'a
strictement rien à voir avec l'histoire
américaine
hélas faites attention parce que vous
vous trompez de combat un combat pour
plus d'émancipation pour plus
d'instructions pour plus d'éducation à
ça bien sûr pour faire cesser
l'esclavagé qui est aujourd'hui même un
à l'heure où je vous parle le dernier
rapport de l'onu précise que 40 millions
d'esclaves existe de la mauritanie au
pakistan qu'est ce qu'on fait pour eux a
alors que là on remet tout mélanger donc
je pense que c'est vraiment un faux
combat il faut ce qu'il faut plus
d'éducation il faut amener les enfants
sous la statue de colbert par exemple et
leur expliquer calmement et doucement
que la complexité de l'histoire c'est à
dire que colbert est un des grands
artisans 1 de la puissance française
c'est grâce à colbert que la france est
devenue le pays des lumières déjà vous
voyez dans il faut toujours rappeler la
chronologie mais effectivement il a sévi
à une époque où se pratique est là
la pratique immonde de l' esclavage là
je suis bien sûr d'accord avec vous mais
quand on replace dans le contexte de 785
effectivement les choses apparaissent
très différemment alors justement
abordons le cas colbert puisque non
seulement ces statues étaient vivants
d'alizée aujourd'hui même devant
l'assemblée nationale
mais il ya une salle à l'assemblée
nationale qui s'appelle la salle colbert
et un certain nombre de députés
voudraient la débaptiser dont jean marc
ayrault ancien premier ministre le cas
colbert est intéressant parce
qu'effectivement il faudrait mettre les
enfants devant la statue de colbert et
leur expliquer qu'ils étaient colbert et
par exemple leur expliquer que c'est pas
lui qui a promulgué le code noir par
exemple puisque vous l'avez dit 785 il
était mort colbert en 785 était déjà
mort depuis deux ans c'est son fils qui
a rédigé le code noir ça n'est pas
colbert et on pourrait leur dire aussi
que pour l'époque
le code noir c'était un progrès
puisqu'il donnait aux esclaves des
colonies françaises des droits que leur
refuser leur maître et qui n'existait
nulle part ailleurs le droit d'être
considéré comme un être humain et non
plus comme une chose le droit de se
marier le droit de ne pas être séparé de
sa femme et de ses enfants le droit de
se reposer le dimanche et les jours de
fête le droit de s'instruire le droit
d'être enterré au cimetière etc etc mais
par la même occasion pourrait dire aussi
de colbert que c'est lui qui en
favorisant l'industrie sucrière qui
était le pétrole de l'époque à implanter
des plantations aux orties fait venir
des esclaves africains ça c'est bien lui
et à ce titre
effectivement faut-il le célébrer alors
je vous passe la parole françoise vergès
est ce que colbert nous pose un problème
particulier
oui colbert pose un peu un problème
particulier et le code noir ne donne pas
tellement le droit aux esclaves voudrais
quand même pas exagérer je veux dire
veillée de légifère d'état de torture
d'état de punition si le silane
l'esclave de marolles ne s'échappe
s'enfuit
c'est quand même toute une époque d'une
extrême brutalité et je voudrais
rappeler qu'il ya des citoyens français
qui sont descendants d'esclaves à la
martinique en guadeloupe en guyane et à
la réunion
donc on est pas en train de parler des
états unis on n'attrape pas en train de
parler d'une américanisation on est en
train de parler de nous
aujourd'hui de nous qui sommes ici en
france et dans notre histoire d
absolument n'a aucune importance je ne
vois pas pourquoi il n'y a pas une
statue de louis delgres s par exemple
ont un statut de toussaint louverture où
on m'aime pas simplement des statuts
parce que je ne suis pas non plus pour
la multiplication de statut j'ai peur je
pense qu'on pourrait remplacer parfois
de certains statuts par des arbres
pourquoi pas qu'il ya une forêt à la
place de la statue de gallieni ou de
houe de lyautey mais pour pour revenir
bien sûr c'est la question dont on va
venir des petits enfants on ne va pas
faire venir tous les petits-enfants de
france devant la statue de colbert
il n'y a quand même une statuaire je
dire si je passe devant nationale
l'assemblée nationale je vois poids ce
qu'on leur présente comme la nation des
hommes qui légifèrent dont un d'entre
eux qui a contribuer effectivement à la
puissance française comme une puissance
esclavagiste donc évidemment je peux
trouver que évidemment on peut certains
vont trouver que c'est là ça correspond
à la grandeur de la france
moi je trouve que ça correspond à un
certain moment quand on me dit que tout
le monde pratiqué l'esclavagé leopard
mais c'est quand même une certaine j'ai
pas c'est un argument je trouve ça
étrange puisqu'il y avait déjà des
personnes très tôt qui s'opposa
esclavage très près tout d'abord les
premiers personnes qui s'opposent à
lescar âge ce sont les escarres de même
donc à prix doux tout le monde n'était
pas d'accord ce n'est pas un drain il y
avait des révoltes sur des routes de
traite y avait des révoltes dans les
baraques y avait des révoltes des
navires négriers il y avait des révoltes
sont les plantations donc il ya eu une
opposition l esclavage tout de suite
donc pourquoi ce ne serait pas cette
opposition qui serait célébrée de dire
que tout le monde accepte une spirale
n'ont absolument pas tous les millions
d'africains qui ont été déportés
n'acceptez pas l'esclavagé n'allons pas
accepter ni les amérindiens qui ont été
analysées avant ni même par exemple les
quelques européens qui avaient été
emmenés en commun appelé sous contrat
dans les colonies pendant tout un temps
les personnes ne se sont pas non parce
qu'on n'est pas vrai que tout le monde
accepte et la servitude ce n'est pas
vrai du tout il ya eu très très tôt dès
le départ des révoltes des insurrections
des oppositions donc cette l'argument
colbert finalement c'est quand même
c'est une certaine approche de
l'histoire mais on peut si on d
si tu que c'est celle là qu'il faut
mettre en avant c'est un choix ce n'est
pas du tout quelque chose de neutre
c'est un absolument un choix qui n'est
pas un choix histoire qui est un choix
d'une certaine culture qui est mise en
avant il est certes un récit qui est
valorisé dimitri casali oui avant de
vous expliquer qu'ils étaient colbert
une chose très importante
déjà il ne faut jamais oublier un creux
xviie siècle la grande historienne
catherine catherine coquery vidrovitch a
expliqué qu'un africain sur quatre était
un esclave d'un autre africain avant
même l'arrivée des européens
donc ça justifie fondamentale et c'est
ce que je vous dis le monde entier
jusqu'au japon jusqu'au sociétés
amérindiennes pratiqué l'esclavagé
enfin je vais vous expliquer qu'ils
étaient colbert colbert c'est un des
plus grands créateurs de la france c'est
à dire que non seulement il a porté la
puissance comme on en a parlé tout à
l'heure mais il a apporté son génie
cerise artistique c'est à dire toutes
les académies de musique de sculptures
de peinture des beaux-arts il était sûr
attendant des bâtiments c'est lui c'est
à lui que l'on doit à versailles
c'est lui qui a trouvé les deniers pour
fabriquer ce château que la chine que
les américains que le monde entier nous
qu'aux petits voiliers renier colbert
c'est renier une part de l'âme française
ça il faut bien le comprendre
enfin c'est grâce à ce rayonnement
artistique et intellectuelle de coco
colbert a provoqué que la france a pu
advenir au siècle des lumières et c'est
le siècle des lumières qui a qui a
produit tous ces beaux idéaux ses
principes de liberté d'égalité
d'émancipation à que je revendique aussi
en tant que républicain et dont je suis
fier c'est la france qui a créé cet
universalisme et l'angleterre et la
france sont les deux seuls pays au monde
les deux premiers à avoir aboli l
esclavage l'angleterre en 1830 et la
france en 1848
donc vous voyez vous trompez de combat
il faut combattre les esclavagistes
aujourd'hui en libye à l'heure où je
vous parle il est ils vendent des
esclaves 400 euros
un des esclaves noirs se vante sur les
marchés de tripoli 400 euros au pakistan
plus de 40% des jeunes filles n'ont pas
le droit d'aller à l'école
voilà les combat d'émancipation
d'éducation parce que là attention avec
ce taux ce combat complètement
anachronique
ce faux combat vous aller creuser le
fossé entre les communautés et vous
allez diviser la france encore plus et
nous allons avoir une société de haine
de rancoeur et surtout l'ignorance
voilà monsieur je ne vous fais pas la
leçon de l'histoire
je viens d'une côte du noun départements
dits français où il ya encore des
esclaves et qui est très marquée par
l'esclavagé
donc je trouve que vraiment c'est assez
incroyable de me faire la leçon là
dessus si par exemple à la réunion la
martinique à la guadeloupe de la guyane
yens encore at-elle racines de telles
inégalités de telles injustices que les
noirs descendants d'esclaves sont
absolument n'ont pas le même accès à la
santé à l'éducation qu'à un taux de
chômage à 3 ya que les monocultures ont
été imposées de la banane du sucre du
café
je veux dire ce n'est en rien à voir
être la libye alors évidemment il ya des
choses en épi je suis d'accord pour les
combats mais je suis en france je
combats le racisme en france et les
inégalités et les injustices qu'ils sont
en vacances et qui sont ici de
l'esclavagé enfin quand on me dit tout
le monde avait des esclaves
j'aurais jeudi tout le monde avait des
esclaves mais ce n'est pas les
esclavages africain qui a produit le
monde dans lequel nous vivons qui a
amené la modernité ce n'est pas
l'esclavagé un truc hein ce n'est pas
les stades africains qui a colonisé les
caraïbes et les amériques amérique du
nord amérique centrale et amérique du
sud ou dans l'océan indien
je n'ai jamais vu ce n'est pas peut donc
d'une part quand on dit tout le monde
avait des esclaves et qu'évidemment les
africains aussi c'était on veut
absolument minimiser la responsabilité
des européens qui ont quand même
organisé une trêve pendant des siècles
et qui ont créé effectivement tout avant
de nouveau comme ce qu'ils appellent le
monde nouveau qui était basé sur cette
exploitation
l' esclavage en afrique n'a pas
transformé le monde de la même manière
l'esclavagé colonial et vous pouvez le
dévot aux yeux ce n'est pas vrai par
exemple l'europe consomme du sucre du
canari grata et ce n'est pas à cause de
l' esclavage africain
à cause des plantations dans les
caraïbes des plantations aux états unis
donc de toutes façons et labrador bon
normand dont condamnant toutes les
traites et tous les esclavages mais nous
voulons quand même signaler que
l'esclavagé colonial pratiqué dans tous
les pays européens et d'une part pour la
france quand vous dites c'est le premier
pays qui a aboli l'esclavagé
rappelons que c'est aussi le seul pays
qui l'a rétabli après la première
abolition de l'esclavagé en 1794
c'est le seul pays d'europe qui rétablit
l'esclavagé en 1802 avec napoléon et
donc il faut attendre encore un deuxième
république la seconde république en 1148
pour l'abolir définitivement donc on
n'est pas du tout dans une histoire de
progrès où tout le monde serait comme ça
diraient ils se dirigeraient
merveilleusement vers le progrès c'est
une histoire avec des reculs
c'est une histoire où par exemple quand
les guadeloupéens sont devenus libres
napoléon envoie ses troupes pour écraser
pour rétablir esclavage et donc il ya la
rébellion avec nous et d'allégresse et
les gens sont massacrés
je ne trouve pas que y ait de quoi se
vanter là dessus et ce n'est pas un
révisionnisme de le faire puisque la
proclamation louis delgrès c'est une
proclamation qui dit la liberté ou la
mort
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est tout à fait
capable d'écrire un texte une
proclamation de la liberté ça ne vient
pas de la france c'est quelqu'un en
guadeloupe un guadeloupéen qui le fait
donc c'est une question de justice
ce n'est pas de dire qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution liste en france c'est de
dire que les premiers abolitionnisme
parce que pour eux c'est une question de
vie et de mort étaient les personnes qui
étaient esclavagisés et qui n'ont pas
arrêté de lutter pour la liberté
l'égalité justement pour ces choses qui
sont si importants et qu'ils ont fait
avancer cette histoire la révolution
haïtienne a énormément fait avancer
cette histoire donc la question n'est
pas de remplacer une histoire par une
autre est de dire que c'est de dire
qu'il faut reconnaître c'est par
d'histoire il faut quand même entendre
les voix des personnes qui parlent et
qu'ils sont qui sont des descendants
d'esclaves et les africains eux mêmes
sont en train de faire leur travail sur
l'islam a jeté hier mattrick au maroc il
ya eu un livre sur l'esclavagé au maroc
et le fait d'être noir au maroc dont ce
travail se fait même dans les pays
arabes et dans des pays musulmans ce
travail se fait de plus en plus
donc il y à une avancée dans la
recherche il se plaît pas à la recherche
européenne qui est la plus en avance sur
ces questions une question
complémentaire à ce que vous venez de
dire françoise vergès il ya la statue de
victor schoelcher qui a été vandalisée
en martinique ça a beaucoup choqué parce
qu'on a dit c'est quand même l'homme qui
a aboli l'esclavagé
il est d'ailleurs devenu le député de la
martinique est la suite de cela mais en
même temps ceux qui ceux qui avaient
vandalisé la statue ont fait savoir que
au fond c'est toujours la même chose on
croit que c'est nous les blancs pour
faire simple qui avons octroyé la
liberté aux esclaves et qu'on est très
sympa dans leur grande mansuétude de
l'avoir fait et par la même occasion on
a oublié que ce sont les martyrs les
esclaves noirs de martinique eux mêmes
qui ont aboli l'esclavagé en 1848 en se
révoltant et le gouverneur de la
martinique a été obligé d'abolir
l'esclavagé
avant l'arrivée du décret signé par
chercheurs etc en vandalisant la statue
de chercheurs ça n'était évidemment pas
contre schoelcher
mais c'est une façon de dire pourquoi
élèves dont une statue s à chercheurs et
pas aux esclaves qui se sont révoltés à
ce moment là pourquoi est ce que comme
vous le disiez il n'y a pas de statut à
toussaint louverture qui est le premier
à voir à s'être révoltés avoir la baule
il esclavage
etc etc deux vitrines dimitri casali est
ce que ça ne pose pas un problème
effectivement qu'à chaque fois les
blancs et encore une fois je ne parle
d'une catégorie sociale un pas de vous
ou moi mais on a tendance à toujours se
voir comme la solution de tous les
problèmes de l'humanité ait jamais on
aime bien se voir comme comme chercheur
et jamais comme une partie du problème
au fond et de rendre aux autres le fait
que parfois ils ont résolu le problème
sans nous avant de parler de toussaint
louverture j'aimerais encore une
parenthèse
n'oublions jamais et c'est intéressant
parce que vous l'avez pas oublier un la
traite arabo musulmane qui a commencé au
septième siècle qui ne qui n'est même
pas terminé aujourd'hui à et qui a
déporté plus de 18 millions a donc
j'aimerais bien que vous demandiez des
comptes à l'arabie saoudite 1 à l'egypte
quoi des robots pays du golfe ça c'est
sûr que là bas on rogne on tente rien on
tente toujours dans les régimes
démocratiques comme la france ou
l'angleterre pour revenir à toussaint
louverture il pose un problème changer
très intéressant parce que personne et
chercheurs bien sûr y'a pas assez de
statut de noir ça je vous la corde mais
toussaint louverture va poser un
problème certain parce qu'il faut savoir
que lui même posséder une plantation
avec 12 esclaves donc dans un sens il
est aussi un esclavagiste donc je suis
d'accord pour élever plus de deux
statues pour les noix bien sûr des
personnages comme joséphine baker dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure il faut
savoir qu'en france a essayé les
ancêtres de françoise chandernagor il y
à il y un qui l'ont prouvé il existait
une loi en france qui remontait un édile
de 13 115 dès qu'un esclave touché la
terre de france il était automatiquement
libéré c'est ce qui est arrivé aux
ancêtres de françoise chandernagor la
grand écrivain qu'il ya débat qui aura
des barres car mars à marseille et qui a
été libéré automatiquement et donc après
bien sûr il ya tous ces personnages
absolument haut en couleur dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
severiano de heredia et le premier maire
de mars de paris et thé noir en 1879
après blaise diagne et a été le premier
député français noirs à l'assemblée
nationale alors
il faut attendre 1965 aux états unis
pour avoir en dira un sénateur noir
ensuite contrairement à ce que dit
virginie despentes des ministres noir il
n'y en a chaque année depuis 1931
et c est bien sûr alain koffi yamgname
ya peu il ya peu de temps la semaine
dernière l'ancien ministre de françois
mitterrand a rappelé que pour lui il n'y
avait pas de problème noire en france et
il a dit la semaine dernière
donc vous voyez il faut pas plaquer
encore ses représentations mentales
américaine anglo saxon pour en venir au
code noir
c'est vrai que tous les grands
spécialistes que ce soit pétré
grenouilleau 1 où jean ferrat
jean-françois niort disent que le code
noir fut un progrès louis xiv louis xv
colbert est un grand législateur c'est
ça encore une fois qu'il faut il faut
lui rendre grâce
il a écrit il a rédigé plus d'une
dizaine de code il a rédigé le code
louis l'ancêtre du code civil il a
rédigé le code des eaux et forêts a
toujours opérationnels aujourd'hui il a
rédigé le code de service maritime de la
marine
il a rédigé le premier code de commerce
et donc c'est on lui a demandé de
légiférer de réglementer l'esclavagé
effectivement il a fait et ce n'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut abattre sa sa stature
et le poids d'un personnage aussi
considérable de l'histoire de france et
hong kong 0 mais je voudrais juste vous
donne la parole tout de suite mais il
faut juste qu'il est rédigé plein de
code sauf le code noir encore une fois
c'est son fils ad-pa colbert il était
mort il reste une minute une minute
avant la pause françois cevert je
l'avais pendant une minute jamais cru
dire laquelle la question sur l'arabie
s'est dit qu'on nous sort tout le temps
les question d'aller demander des
comptes à l'arabie saudite d'abord moi
je suis pas le gouvernement français qui
vendent des armes constamment l'arabie
saoudite
et quand on devant lutter pour que les
personnes en arabie soudite et plus de
droits nous sommes dans la rue et
nouvelle fiston moi je suis réunionnaise
je ne parle pas et je peux citer jean
piat sadon au lieu de pétré grenouilleau
on pourrait citer michel rouleau qui est
je dire pourquoi les historiens que vous
citez sont tous des historiens de côté
je dis pourquoi il n'ya absolument même
pas la parole donnée
rien quoi doper d'un historien haïtiens
qui voit les choses différemment
je veux dire pourquoi alors leur travail
leurs travaux n'ont pas d'importance il
ya l'intérêt
pourquoi faut-il toujours que je peux
ils ont une autre vision de cette
question du code madeleine autres
commissions de cette question d'
esclavage et de noray dire de la traite
arabo musulmane mais c'est vraiment en
plus je dirais les descendants
d'esclaves et vivre en france sont les
descendants d'esclaves des colonies
françaises ne sont pas les descendants
d'esclaves venant d'arabie séoudite donc
les questions que nous posons sur les
questions qui se posent ici je vous
interromps tous les deux ont fait une
pause et reprend ce débat juste après
[Musique]
l'état a mis sur la table une série de
mesures pour aider le secteur 18
milliards d'euros pour le tourisme là
pour l'instant via les aides encore les
aides et donc que les choses vont se
compliquer à la rentrée voit que ça
parle beaucoup mais il faut il faut du
concret et les fonds de solidarité
2500 euros et ses terrasses et des
pacotilles tout ça c'est c'est mal fait
c'est mal préparée donc comment voulez
vous que les gens s'y retrouvent
le plus dur c'est à venir et c'est là où
on la remonte contrôler ça va être
compliqué de faire revenir les gens pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'on a tous
perdu beaucoup de revenus
donc de toute façon on est on est dans
une impasse
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue et finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
faut-il déboulonner les statues on
reprend ce débat avec françoise vergès
qui est politologue et historienne qui a
publié l'année dernière un féminisme des
colonials la fabrique avec dimitri
casali qui est historien et qui a publié
lui l'année dernière le grand procès de
l'histoire de france
chez robert laffont une autre figure que
j'aimerais qu'on invoque parce qu'elle
pose le problème sous un autre angle
c'est celle du général bugeaud qui a
commis en algérie pendant la conquête de
l'algérie ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
des crimes contre l'humanité il
il extermine est hommes femmes et
enfants les en fumant dans des grottes
et il s'agissait d'un plan précis
ça n'est pas un accident qui serait
arrivé comme ça ça s'est produit à
plusieurs reprises mais alors évidemment
on se dit peut-on juger bijoux qui porte
dont le nom alors c'est à la fois une
avenue dans paris des écoles des lycées
des jardins publics il ya le but joe est
absolument partout en france
alors va-t-on de juger avec les critères
d'aujourd'hui et en même temps il faut
savoir qu'à l'époque les crimes qu'il
commet sont contestées y compris par ses
soldats qui trouve ça absolument
scandaleux aujourd'hui cela va sans dire
que le général bugeaud se retrouveraient
immédiatement devant la cour pénale
internationale ci tentait qu'elle
jugeait autre chose que des africains
mais il le mériterait en tout cas
amplement alors faut-il continuer
d'honorer de célébrer le général bugeaud
en laissant son nom absolument partout
et encore une fois c'est là le le but de
cette question est ce qu'il faut le
juger avec les critères d'aujourd'hui
dimitri casali excellente question
parce qu'effectivement pierre nora le
grand historien a rappelé que l'histoire
est une longue suite de crimes contre
l'humanité c'est ça l'histoire depuis la
nuit des temps un de l'esclavagé comment
on parle aujourd'hui existait depuis les
sociétés les plus ancestrales et cette
horreur et donc effectivement il faut
toujours replacer dans le contexte de
l'époque cet anachronisme l'anachronisme
disait encore marc bloch notre quand
historien et le pire des maux en
histoire donc effectivement lujo a fait
la conquête de l'algérie dans le sang
j'ai moi même écrit un manuel scolaire 1
chez la martinière où j'explique sur la
page de gauche que la conquête de
l'algérie s'est faite dans le sens et
j'ai représenté les fameuses enfumades
du général bugeaud gelé moi même demandé
sur la page de droite
en revanche j'ai insisté sur toute
l'oeuvre sanitaire éducatif infra sud
des infrastructures que la france
coloniale comme on dit ah
réalisé en algérie comme ça l'élève peut
se rendre compte que l'histoire n'est
pas tout noir
elle n'est pas toute blanche elle est
grise est complexe et c'est cette
complexité qui l'art avons passionnante
1 en même temps ces actions positif et
en même temps ces actions négatives
pour en revenir à buzau effectivement je
ne pense pas qu'il faille qu'ils soient
trop présent on peut faire comme les
russes dont vous parlais tout à l'heure
où les pays de l'est qui ont organisé
justement ses statuts dans des parts
dans des parts d immenses où toutes les
statues de lénine de staline sont
concentrés en revanche il faut bien
dissocier et ça on voit bien que c'est
cette longue montée de l'ignorance le
rôle de gallieni faidherbe et lyautey de
bugeaud bugeaud c'est un soldat napoléon
il a encore la guerre de guérillas de
guérilla en espagne c'est les pratiques
là ils ont pu mât des grottes turcs ont
pratiqué dans cette guerre civile
popur populaire horrible en revanche
avec l'arrivée de feder gallieni il ya
une évolution certaine qui se produit
dans la façon de faire la guerre
faidherbe tout d'abord que vous voulez
tous déboulonner il faut savoir la
plupart ne savent pas qu'il avait épousé
une sénégalaise et que son fils était
métis donc pour un raciste
merci gallieni c'est le premier a
théorisé la plaie la pacification des
populations civiles à il demande à ses
officiers des quelconques et un village
de construire un marché et le lendemain
une école donc c'est sûr que l'évolution
s'est produite de bugeaud à à gallieni
c'est il faut plus d'histoire il faut
expliquer et revenir à la chronologie de
l'évolution des esprits et ben et
lyautey bien sûr il a il a théorisé
aussi la pacification des populations
civiles que les américains ont
redécouvert en irak
dix ans après leur erreur colossale vous
savez ils arrivent en 2003 je pense que
c'est en 2010 que le général schwarzkopf
le moins pire des généraux américains
redécouvre les écrits de yachts et et
comprend qu'il faut gagner absolument
l'amitié de tous ces peuples avant de
les de les conquérir à françoise vergès
oui alors que l'histoire est une longue
ce que de crimes contre l'humanité une
histoire est aussi une longue liste de
lutte pour les pour la liberté de
personnes qui chaque jour tout le temps
encore aujourd'hui se lève chaque matin
et vos luttes et de femmes qui
descendent dans la rue qui prennent les
armes qui entretiennent les choses c'est
absolument aussi cela l'histoire
donc on peut trouver évidemment la
position ce n'est que des crimes
toujours les hommes sont des criminels
et on peut aussi prendre la position
justement de cette incroyable aspiration
à la liberté l'égalité qui toujours fait
descendre des personnes dans la rue et
voulait faire bouger
moi je suis de ce côté je suis du côté
des personnes qui savent que peut être
la lutte ne sont elles vraiment pas la
victoire mais il faut lutter pour la
liberté et l'égalité
donc ça c'est une première chose ensuite
la plage je dire l'aspect positif de la
colonisation
on en a quand même beaucoup discuté
après 2005 quand il en avait été
question ça sera enseignée dans les
écoles
je peux dire que finalement on quand on
regarde par exemple en 1945 quand aimé
césaire via l'assemblée nationale et
présente un tableau de des colonies
esclavagiste c'est absolument
catastrophique
après trois siècles de colonisation
française il n'y a rien il n'y a pas
d'éducation pratiquement très peu de
personnes ont accès à l'éducation
il ya une misère totale il ya des
maladies qui ravagent et c'est une
colonie française non celle concédée en
forme cieux relisez le discours de
césaire non plus que je connais très
bien césaire relisez le discours de
césaire à l'assemblée nationale en 1945
vous ne pouvez pas me dire que c'est pau
il s'agit il suffit de le relire il
était un tableau extrêmement négatif
quand dont il fera un tableau pas
extrêmement négatif de la colonisation
française
aimé césaire d'accord en 1945 et peu
après il est ya la départementalisation
quand on relit tous et pour reprise de
barbe à l'assemblée nationale il
continue à absolument critique et parce
que le fait qu'il n'y a toujours pas
d'égalité donc bugeaud gallieni pour moi
ce sont des criminels
exactement quand et comment il a été dit
ce serait dire je ne vois pas ce que
galliani a fait quand vous dites que vu
jouer il a épousé une sénégalaise
mais évidemment tout le monde tout le
monde peut avoir dans un mini forêt
d'argonne racisme structurel
et donc gagner le neuf les malgaches le
souvenir des malgaches
peut-être que les malgaches n'ont pas
d'importance mais les malgaches le
souvenir qu'ils ont de gallieni n'est
pas du tout que de quelqu'un qui a fait
du bien à leur ville
aujourd'hui encore le souvenir de gagny
était souvenirs négatifs dans la langue
bagages
il faut parfois peut-être se mettre du
côté des personnes qui ont subi tout
cela et non pas simplement des écrits
bijoux ou des écrits de gallieni ou des
écrits de faidherbe
mais qu'est ce que les africains qu'est
ce que les malgaches qu'est ce que les
vietnamiens ont dit de leurs de leurs
actions il s'est quand même ces
personnes ces femmes et ces hommes
existent leur vie leur opinion quand
même content
les vicomtes sévi contre je vois pas
pourquoi dans la question de l'algérie
de deux jours gallieni feder on ne
dirait que les écrits de faidherbe
gallieni du jour non on ne verrait rien
de ce qui vient des personnes qui les
voyaient arriver dans leur pays pour
absolument massacré brûlé faire la
politique de la terre brûlée
c'est une vision puisque vous voulez pas
vous parler d' équilibre c'est une
vision qui serait un peu plus équilibré
d'écouter aussi les ce que les femmes
lisant ont perçu et ont vécu de leur
côté camp gallieni bugeaud ou fédère
arrive chez eux et qu'ils ils ont
peut-être construit des ponts et des
hôpitaux et quelques écoles mais pour
les personnes quand on relit tous les
textes et les témoignages les personnes
l'écrasement de personnes qui refusent
le travail forcé qui refusent de payer
l'impôt
ce n'est absolument pas une vision tout
à fait positif de la colonisation
donc et c'est encore là je sais pas
rétrospectivement c'est pas des taxes
d'aujourd'hui c'est des textes de
l'époque c'est pas des textes de
maintenance et paffett respectifs assez
bonne vision américaine rôle de saxon ce
sont des malgaches qui écrivent ce sont
des personnes étaient des égalités
crimes et les malgaches
quand les malgaches fragments quelque
chose je trouve que ça mérite d'être
écouté
je ne vois pas pourquoi je trouverais
que les malgaches n'ont rien à dire sur
ce que gagner ni fait quand il vient
dans leur pays se tiendront on va parler
d'avoir et avec une monarchie développer
gallieni arrive institué la première
chose qu'il fait c'est d'instituer le
travail forcé etc il y aura des mines
à gages qui vont mourir dans le travail
forcé et ils vont encourager la
colonisation de madagascar en faisant
venir même des gens de la réunion je ne
vois absolument pas quand on dit cela
justement ce qui m'intéresserait moins
ceux de comprendre c'est pourquoi on
fait des héros nationaux de ces
personnes puisque comme frédéric taddeï
le rappeler il y à des personnes qui
s'opposent à la colonisation qui s'y
opposent dans le temps même c'est pas
des prospectives c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est dans le temps même de la
colonisation car bugeaud par fédéraux ou
par gallieni que des voix s'opposent à
ses seins ça et on le sait quand le
discours de jules ferry sur des races
supérieures de renseigner les reims
enfin ça perdure il ya des oppositions
dans l'assemblée nationale donc ce n'est
pas moi qu'il dit qu'il serait trop
américanisé ou droit anglo saxon et ce
sont des personnes dans l'époque et donc
on voit bien tout ça n'a pas entraîné
l'adhésion est donc pourquoi c'est ce
sont ces personnes qui sont transformés
en héros nationaux pourquoi ce sont ces
personnes qui sont présentés comme des
vies à dévider exemple à la jeunesse
française
c'est quand même ça la question parce
que déjà à l'époque il y avait des
contestations gens nous donnent pas de
me dire que c'est d'aujourd'hui que
c'est une vue anachronique de l'histoire
je me demandais ce que poser à la
colonisation de la kanaky
je vous arrête parce que ce débat sur
les aspects positifs ou pas de la
colonisation
ça dure en france depuis nicolas sarkozy
si je me souviens bien continuons plutôt
d'autres débats dans ce qu'il a de
nouveau justement à savoir ses statuts
qui nous regardent et que nous regardons
on sait bien pourquoi les statuts sont
là elles sont là pour l'édification
l'édification des citoyens c'est là ça
vient d'en haut la statue
c'est en eau qu'on nous dise voilà voilà
une statue d'un homme ou d'une femme
célèbre essai pour l'édification de ceux
d'en bas
aujourd'hui ce qui change c'est que ceux
d'en bas peut rêver exprimer leur
opinion et au fond aujourd'hui est-ce
que ça n'est pas ça le problème
il faudrait tenir compte de toutes les
sensibilités de toutes les minorités de
toutes les diversités pas seulement des
malgaches à savoir que pensait-il de ce
que nous envoyons à l'époque pour les
colonisés mais de ceux qui aujourd'hui
habite avec nous et voilée même statut
que doux et là ça pose un problème
effectivement qui ne qui n'existaient
pas autant on à élever des statues à
bugeaud et aux autres il n'y avait pas
tellement de ses descendants de ces
victimes qui étaient qui était en france
alors faut-il qu on te dira compte de
toutes les sensibilités aujourd'hui et
j'ai une question subsidiaire à ce
moment-là reste-t-il des gens à qui on
va pouvoir élever des statues
parce que si vous demandez bien sûr
propos d'henri iv les catholiques vous
dire qu'il a quand même en tant que chef
des protestants chef de guerre il en a
tué quand même beaucoup louis xiv lui la
chasse et les protestants de france les
protestants j'imagine vont pas être
d'accord
napoléon vous l'avez dit la rétablit
l'esclavagé donc je pense qu'ils vont
pas être d'accord quant au général de
gaulle
il a dit que le peuple juif était sûr de
lui et dominateur ce que beaucoup ne
l'ont pas pardonné et en plus les
divorcés n'était pas reçue à l'elysée de
là à ce que les divorcés se plaignent
donc est ce qu'il reste quelqu'un
peut-être même même pasteur
on va plus pouvoir lui élevé de statut
ya trop de gens qui sont contre les
vaccinations maintenant dimitri qu'à
l'habitude
c'est ce que je dis ouais c'est ce que
je disais ouais je vous laisse et les
bains je vous ai laissé parler sur
madagascar
en fait il faut vraiment absolument
comprendre qu'en fait si on va par là on
va devoir déboulonner plus de 80% des
personnages historiques
ca c il va falloir si on suit votre
raisonnement la france doit déboulonner
toutes les statues de jules césar qui a
massacré un million de gaulois et a
rendus esclaves
un autre million on va devoir demander
des comptes à l'italie si on va par là
charlemagne un des plus grand massacreur
de saxon si on va par là bien sûr plus
grave les purs et moi qui ai écrit et
aller les grands immigrés cubains qui
ont fait la france en géorgie tient
beaucoup
bien sûr qu'il faut représenter plus de
héros noirs dans nos statuts mais aussi
à des personnages il faut être
extrêmement ambigu le grand jaurès le
grand jean jaurès lui même a parlé du
rôle super delà des races supérieures
léon blum un le chantre du front
populaire a parlé de la supériorité des
blancs est le plus grand de tous
victor hugo est-ce qu'on va devoir alors
que la france je vous le rappelle a
représenté à de nombreux moments de
l'histoire de l'humanité l'espoir des
hommes depuis les bâtisseurs des
cathédrales 1 l'art français comme on le
disait alors l'humanisme de montaigne le
siècle des lumières qui a produit cette
demande des morts si passion de liberté
d'égalité qui a permis au peuple de se
libérer du joug colonial
ça c'est grâce à sa jules-ferry qu'a
voulu éduquer tous à l'école gratuite
public est obligatoire du grand jules
ferry sap donner la possibilité à deux
de construire une élite et tous ces
peuples ont pu se libérer de l'emprise
française
mais quand on replace dans le contexte
de l'époque déjà on s'aperçoit que la
france était beaucoup plus favorable que
les régimes anglo saxons anglais qui
n'ont pas fait dans la dentelle et sans
parler des portugais et des espagnols
d'un qui était beaucoup plus dur que
nous et aujourd'hui justement qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire on va devoir des baptisés
regardez ma mois shing tonnes
j'aime rappeler cet exemple washington
aux etats unis george washington et est
possesseur d'une plantation de 100
esclaves
thomas jefferson 200 esclaves qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire les américains ils ont
débaptisé leur propre capital
vous rendez compte dans quelle ineptie
dans quelle hystérie collective
hier je regardais la presse américaine
savez-vous ce qu'ils ont titré ils ont
titré que la musique classique était
raciste
vous voyez dans quelle folie nous sommes
en train de sombrer un peu grâce à vous
1 on est en train de fracturer la
société française qui était beaucoup
plus uni comme disait kofi yamgname tous
ces noirs dont je vous parlais qui
mérite une statue c'est évidemment félix
éboué gaston monnerville qui était le
troisième personnage de l'état à de
design 1958 à 1969
il faut rappeler que la france ne s'est
pas des états unis ce n'est pas les
états unis et que malheureusement avec
votre vos actions vous allez provoquer
une fracture ou le vivre ensemble ne
sera plus possible
retenez ce que je vous dis au lion va
vivre face à face et on va mourir
séparément
alors je voudrais ici je peux me la
fracture elle existe déjà laissé chez
certaines femmes à ces mouvements elle
existe une barrière la pression existe
déjà depuis longtemps avec joseph sont
appelés je pense aujourd'hui léonora
miano dans le monde disait quelque chose
de très juste c'est sans doute parce que
ce sont des noirs et des arabes comme on
dit et des asiatiques qui demandent
justice que ça fait controverse
je ne suis pas sûr que si par exemple
des femmes avaient demandé qu'on
remplace la statue peut-être de feder
par la statue de simone veil ou du
simone de beauvoir ça aurait fait une
telle controverse
la question ce que ce que nous demandons
c'est que l'histoire
cette histoire ces personnes là on ne
soit plus dans l'espace public donc il
ya quand même quelque chose qui est tous
les cas pendants d'oreille mais alors
qu'est ce qu'on ferait de jules ferrer
question préfecture hugo tout ça c'est
un peu pour évacuer le problème qui est
posé
profondément par cette question et
qu'elle y est aujourd'hui aux grands
mouvements antiracistes qui lie à dans
le monde
levy noir comptes qui a été posée à
partir de là les caisses de la question
des dates déboulonnage des statuts
apprend pagne ce mouvement né
le seule personne d'entre nous ne croit
que en déboulonnant les statuts on va
mettre fin au contrôle au faciès ou aux
violences policières
mais on le sait que ça une grande
importance malgré tout là où ça dit
quelque chose alors on va pas je n'ai
pas parlé des amériques des états unis
parce qu'on va nous accuser d'être
complètement anglo saxons comme si nous
n'étions absolument pas capables de
penser par nous-mêmes
ça c'est l'accusation vous n'êtes pas
capables de penser par vous même il faut
que ce soit les américains qui est
bouddhiste vous n'arrêtez pas de les
imiter fret allait rappeler que le
premier geste déboulonnage des statuts
et lieu en martinique le 22 mai bien
avant que la statue de coleson tombe à
bristol en angleterre le 6 juin
donc apparemment c'était pas les anglo
saxons ce n'était pas les américains
c'étaient des jeunes martiniquais qui
avait une réputation prestigieux
partenaires donc sur chercheurs etc
donc chaque fois qu'on nous donne et
voilà qu'est ce qu'on va faire à victor
hugo et qu'est ce qu'on va faire des
martins et pour éviter la question que
nous posons
quand est-ce que physiquement il y aura
plus de justice quand est ce qu'il y
aura une justice mémorial quand est ce
que seront pris en compte et la question
dont des statues ou des monuments parce
qu'il ne peut pas avoir que des statues
ça peut être aussi une réflexion sur la
manière de représenter dans l'espace
public
un autre récit ça peut être des fraises
que j'en sais rien je ne suis pas
nécessairement fixé sur la question que
ce statut doit être une question
collective et on doit entendre les voix
de ces personnes qui comme les honneurs
ammiano le fait remarquer c'est elles
qui font scandale
c'est pas la demande de remplacement de
statut quand on a demandé de remplacer
l'institution demande est là un saint la
ctu de pétain ça n'aurait pas provoqué
une controverse et je répète je suis sûr
que si on demandait de déplacer la
statue de ces dern pour la remplacer par
simone veil ou simone de beauvoir peu
importe ça n'aurait pas cette
controverse ce qu'il fait contreverse
c'est que c'est ça fait partie du combat
antiraciste et que de dire que ces
statues contribuent par leur présence à
quelques a effectivement à la permanence
et à la maintenance des racisme
structurel la fracture elle existe elle
n'est pas du tout amené par ses
mouvements
ce n'est pas parce qu' elle
manifestation devant la statue de gagny
qui la fracture dans la société
française
société française avec fracture et qui
est mort qui manifestent dans la rue ce
sont les soignants qui étaient là au
premier plan au premier rang pendant la
crise je ne crois pas ou en quoi les
mouvements les quelques mouvements qui
demande sa fracture et je voudrais qu'on
arrête de nous parler d'anglo saxons et
d' américanisation nous sommes
absolument capables de penser par
nous-mêmes nous écrivons des livres nous
faisons des études
nous étudions toutes les choses dont
crayons des associations nous examinons
comment les as peuvent être des
colonisés nous avons des artistes avec
nous nous avons des écrivains avec nous
ne sommes pas juste une bande de
marginaux qui ne savons pas ce que nous
faisons nous avons pensé nous
travaillons nous partons de nous mêmes
nous partons que des choses de dire ça
ne peut pas se faire sans nous ce qui se
fait sans nous comme di celmo nelson
mandela se fait contre nous dimitri
casali oui il n'y a pas de pays plus
égalitaires au monde peut-être à que la
france c'est ça qu'il faut rappeler dès
qu'on regarde le contexte
allez vivre au pakistan allez vivre en
amérique latine aller vivre en afrique
aujourd'hui vous avez ce qui se passe
avec les élections du congo complètement
corrompu a hélas les coloniaux les
européens n'y sont pour rien donc en
fait il faut pas fausser le problème des
premières statues ont été déboulonnées
aux amériques
abbas était la statue de richmond du
général lee on revient toujours aux
états unis malheureusement les états
unis tout ce qui se passe en amérique
arrive dix ans après et malheureusement
à nous comme je vous ai rappelés depuis
tout à l'heure la france n'a strictement
rien à voir avec les états unis
aujourd'hui ils ont même aux états unis
déboulonner la statue du lys grant le
général du nord qui avait donc qu'ils
étaient contre inquiété pour l'abolition
des esclavages et qui avait vaincu le
sud esclavagiste vous rendez compte dans
quel degré de folie
il leur reste et il était tellement
sauvage des vrais barbares ils ont
déboulonné la statue de cervantès
cervantes son soi-disant un symbole de
la rue de l'expansionnisme n'est ce pas
hispanique
ils ne savent même pas que cervantès
était un esclave blanc
dans les geôles de des pays arabes parce
qu'il faut rappeler aussi quelque chose
que tout le monde ignore plus
l'esclavagé était tellement pratiqué
dans l'histoire que 1 millions 5,2
blancs européens ont pourri dans les
geôles d'alger de tunis de tripoli et ça
et cervantès le premier donc vous voyez
on est en train de plaquer un faux
problème la lutte antiraciste les droits
civiques ont été re reconnu en 1965 et
avec raison
et alors que quand les américains
arrivent en france les musiciens je
parle de signer des chèques en 1925 de
miles davis et et de jimi hendrix
il dit qu ils disent que c'est le pari
est le paradis les noirs a écrit signer
bechet
1 est ce que vous le savez ça illégaux
donc c'est ça c'est ça il faut pas se
tromper de combat
et là je dis attention parce
qu'effectivement on ne pourra plus vivre
ensemble vous suivre on efface notre
histoire un peuple amnésique comme la
france comme tous les pays vont le
devenir puisque ça se produit aussi en
grande bretagne vous avez vu qu'ils ont
ils ont attaqué la statue du grand
churchill 1 qu'il n'y a pas plus anti
raciste que le winston churchill
quand on connaît véritablement créé
mémoire il ce qu'il a écrit mais non il
a déclarations c'est churchill c'est un
personnage haut en couleur alors
effectivement il parlait des chinois ils
disaient les chinetoques mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'il était raciste pour l'ong
1920 à la tribune de la sdn il dit il
dit le peuple juif est un des plus
grands juil aps peuple de toute
l'histoire de l'humanité il écrit ça en
1920 et c'est de toute façon c'est grâce
à lui que l'état d'israël en particulier
pour vous avez reçu je vous interromps
parce qu'il reste plus que trois minutes
mais il ya bien pire que churchill il ya
grandi gandhi est accusé d'avoir été
raciste et d'avoir été âpre entre à
predator sexuelle la question la
question quand on dit excellent départ
et sauvage et des barbares aux états
unis qui font ceci et cela sur les
statuts après l'assassinât en direct de
jean claude je trouve que de parler de
sauvages et de barbares aux états unis
alors que vraiment qu'ils sont les
sauvages et les barbares sinon le ces
policiers qui assassine en direct mais
bon on goûte tranquillement en regardant
tranquillement monsieur je vous ai
laissé parler vous laisser parler en
regardant travail à grégoire le premier
caisson et la violence est ce qui fait
violence à béziers sauvage qu'est ce qui
est à revoir
ça c'est une première chose pour revenir
à la france puisque on arrête chaque
fois cette utilisation des états unis
parfois pour dire que c'est un pays
absolument horrible où parfois pour dire
que c'est un pays formidable n'a aucun
intérêt n'a strictement aucun intérêt
la manière dont le racisme est vécue
dans une société peut être effectivement
totalement différente de la france aux
états unis mais quand on va en
martinique quand on ferme kanak et quand
on va en guadeloupe au canton va dans
les quartiers populaires en france
et bien ce qu'on voit ce sont des
violences policières c'est le défenseur
des droits qui le dit ce n'est même pas
manquer la vente c'est le csa qui dit
que finalement ce que les
représentations à la télévision sur des
représentations stigmatisant et c'est en
france que ça se passe
et quand on le défenseur de droits
faisceau son rapport et il le fait en
france l'an dernier quand la commission
nationale des droits de l'homme fait ce
rapport en france et qu'il vient de le
sortir et qu'il parle du racisme anti
noirs en france
ça n'a rien à voir avec importés à moins
que la cndh là à moi donc différent de
droit en programmant effectivement le ca
ca soit des agents de l'anglo saxonne is
bond donc ça c'est on arrête je le
répète nous sommes tout à fait capables
de penser par nous-mêmes nous pensons
par nous mêmes nous crions par nous
mêmes nous avons des expériences nous
nous sommes ancrés dans une expérience
et dans une pratique ne sommes pas des
marionnettes
c'est une insulte que de dire que nous
sommes des marionnettes
nous sommes absolument nous avons étudié
nous avons fait nos études où nous avons
nous avons une expérience nous savons ce
qui nous entoure nous nous intéressons à
ce qui nous entoure nous et
réfléchissent aux nous ne fonctionnons
pas nous sommes capables de nous
remettre en question est effectivement
de savoir que fait-on d'un gandhi que
c'est ton d'un pic togo que fait-on
d'intestin d'ouverture nous sommes
capables de nous poser ces questions
nous n'avons pas dépensé binaire
celui-là est ajouté c'est ce que nous
voulons c'est peut-être que l'espace
public soit penser différemment et que
pourquoi la plupart des statuts en
france sont des statuts de généraux ou
deux personnes qui ont participé élaboré
conceptualiser l'esclavagisme et la
colonisation
pourquoi n'y at-il pas louise michel
pourquoi ne deviennent pas des personnes
qui se sont opposées à cela et je parle
pas d'avoir plus d'hommes noirs oui dans
la tête ça dépend d'abord du
paternalisme
ce qu'on demande c'est que quand je me
promène loin dans l'espace dans paris je
ne suis pas constamment ne me rappelle
pas constamment que ça a été un empire
colonial et de dire que les anglais ont
été pires que les français ça c'est des
discussions absolument de rhétorique
sans aucun intérêt quand il ya des
millions de morts à madagascar
quand il ya des milliers de morts au
vietnam quand il a une guerre inutile au
vietnam aux responsables ont dit l'avoir
danse il n'y a pas eu les élus ont
demandé dans la dépendance
smagge et vos parents vous êtes un
massacre par la française
mais j'avais le remaniement majeur est
tous là donc que je dis est ce que
demain demain pour terminer c'est
beaucoup plus de la lutte antiraciste
est une lutte pour la justice et pour
l'égalité ce n'est pas une lutte pour
fracturer c'est une lutte au contraire
au contraire pour avoir une société plus
paisible où des jeunes noirs et des
jeunes arabes où des jeunes femmes
voilées quand elles sont dans la rue ne
sont pas insulter ne sont pas inventés
huit fois par jour par dans les métros
qu'elle soit accueillie qu'elle plus
exercer leur métier qu'elle puisse avoir
une promotion
et je parle une nouvelle fois des
raccords du défenseur des droits de la
commission nationale des droits humains
de la ligue des droits de l'homme du csa
c'est à dire pas de justement de ce que
vous considérez comme des fractionnistes
je vous enverrai tout on est partant de
ces réalités ne partons pas d'opinion
françoise vergès je suis obligé de vous
interrompre on a dépassé déjà depuis
longtemps le temps de cette émission
merci tous les deux merci dimitri casali
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]